l'offensive russe en ukraine en est à
son 18e jour ce dimanche on apprend
qu'une base située près de la frontière
polonaise a été bombardée le trou le
site je trouve dans la région de lviv
dans l'ouest de l'ukraine une partie du
pays jusqu'ici relativement épargnée par
la guerre premier bilan après peut-être
a évolué neuf morts et 57 blessés selon
le gouverneur de la région de lviv lviv
où nous retrouvons notre correspondant à
une reine puis l'hiver craag gulliver
déjà que sait-on de ce qu'il s'est passé
alors vous l'avez dit le gouverneur
militaire de la région de lviv fait état
de 57 pc est de neuf morts il a dit que
parmi les blessés il y à des civils même
si il a souligné que c'était clairement
une attaque sur une installation
militaire en fait la base des ja bruit
venait pas n'importe quelle installation
militaire car c'est l'endroit où depuis
huit ans déjà sont organisées les
missions d'entraînement des soldats
ukrainiens par les forces des etats-unis
du canada du royaume uni et d'autres
partenaires occidentaux de l'ukraine
donc c'est le lieu symbolique de
l'assistance militaire de l'ukraine par
ses alliés à l'ouest depuis depuis huit
ans déjà depuis le début de la guerre
dans le donbass pour le moment on ignore
s'il y avait des conseillers ou des
trains ou des
ou des entraîneurs étrangers sur la base
au moment de l'attaqué mais on sait que
c'était une attaque assez massive les
roquettes ont été tirées par des avions
que le gouverneur de la région a dit qu
il ne savait pas si ces avions voler
dans l'espace aérienne ukrainiens ou
bien s'il était au dessus par exemple de
la biélorussie ou de la mer noire et
qu'ils ont tiré depuis là-bas de longues
distances
il a dit qu'il y à 23 impacts que les
autorités ukrainiennes sont en train
d'examiner en ce moment ce qu'on peut
relever aussi l'univers c'est que
l'ouest de l'ukraine là où vous êtes
était relativement épargnée jusqu'ici
oui absolument il y a eu quelques
attaques et toujours sur des bases
militaires ou aérienne haloutz que
notamment l'aérodrome a été complètement
détruit il y a deux jours selon le maire
de la ville ludique est une assez grande
ville à plus de 100 km au nord de lviv
où je me trouve actuellement il n'y a
pas eu pour le moment des attaques sur
des cibles civiles dans cette région
mais certainement yavo rif c'est
l'endroit le plus près de lviv qui a été
ciblée pour le moment livre qui est un
peu la capitale de l'ouest de l'ukraine
est aussi le centre par où passent les
déplacés qui essaie d'aller plus loin en
pologne ou bien de s'installer dans
cette région c'est pour le moment un
endroit qui est considérée comme
relativement sûre par rapport au reste
de l'ukraine mais c'est une ville qui se
prépare à une étape potentiel il y à
beaucoup de défense autour de la ville
et il y a beaucoup d'inquiétude ici et
les les sirènes ont sonné pour la
troisième fois de suite en fait ce matin
hier et avant-hier on n'a pas ensuite lu
des informations sur une attaque dans
cette région mais ce matin 6 merci
beaucoup gulliver crâne à lviv dans
l'ouest de l'ukraine